the dolphins quarterback last year who
was benched a couple of times here he is
from yesterday talking about whether and
to what extent he properly was aware of
the team's playbook as a rookie here he
is
in what ways would you say your rookie
season was not up to your standard i
know you've expressed that sentiment in
the past
yeah i i'd say in every aspect um
you know getting to the line of
scrimmage
kind of getting that order of operation
down
um my cadence and then pre-snap reads
you know and then my post snap reads
just just the whole
uh shebang with that um you know i felt
you know i wasn't comfortable with uh
during my my rookie year
um you know so just working on a lot of
those things
uh in year two to you know be better i
think last year for for me last year
wasn't
you know
uh
i i wasn't as comfortable just in
general i wasn't comfortable calling
plays i think the guys that we had last
year were
were phenomenal i i just didn't have
you know the comfortability of
kind of
checking plays alerting plays and doing
that i just rode with the play even if i
knew it in a way that it wasn't gonna
work i was gonna try to make it work so
um
but the the firepower that we have this
year i mean it it's good but
you got to get it out to them too you
know they
you're able to protect yourself and then
get it out to them you know have them
make plays then then you'll be good
so so you're saying that there are
instances last year where you were
executing plays you didn't feel
comfortable with and you didn't feel
comfortable checking into
other plays checking out of those plays
into other place
actually what i'm saying is
i
didn't actually know the like the
playbook necessarily
really really good and that's on no one
else's fault you know but my fault
and they they
our play calls were simple when when i
was in you know i didn't have
alerts and checks
um whereas now you know feeling more
comfortable you know i can kind of
maneuver my way you know through through
these things now
look i'm not surprised by this i
appreciate the candor i appreciate the
follow-up so we have clarity so he
doesn't say later that it was taken out
of context or that's not what he meant
he locked in he's on that story and he's
admitting it and i don't think that's
uncommon that that's my big takeaway as
i listen to it
i think we kind of expect it and it's
the rare rookie who can come in and
immediately pick it up immediately get
it immediately have access to all the
checks that's that's why the older
quarterbacks are so valuable they've
seen it all they've done it all they can
process it this is this is his first
experience
and for some guys it is going to be a
little overwhelming yes definitely and
let's not forget he was also going
through the challenges of like the hip
injury right and all those so that's not
leading you to be comfortable either
like man
man
much much respect for two of us saying
that right there i got a lot of respect
for him for him putting himself out
there that's why
he is a charismatic leader and like guys
follow him and things like that yeah you
would expect that from a rookie but what
you don't expect is for a rookie or a
rookie or a guy going in the second year
to admit some of those things i know
from some people
that tua has told people like that and
privately like you know the nfl
surprised him a little bit that way he
wasn't prepared for maybe the you know
all the offense and things like that but
to me where it's really cool when you're
trying to be the starting quarterback
the face of the franchise the leader of
the team all of those type of things
listen the players on that team are
going to hear that right there they know
the truth they know the offense might
have been less checks with tua or he
might have not been as comfortable or
known the offense quite to the way he
should as a starting quarterback
but
the fact that he answers it like that
instead of getting some political bs
type answer where now the teammates are
watching the news that night going oh
he's lying that's bullcrap he didn't
know the plays or he's making up excuses
and all that now they're going to come
in and be like man our quarterback's
real like he throws himself onto the bus
when he's not like you know up to his
standard and things like that and that
to me is where you gain a lot of respect
from the players and the coaches because
the coaches too of course know the truth
and they're going to see that and be
like look at this guy he took all the
blame he took all the heat he's he's
putting a flash a big spotlight on i
need to be better and that's why he's
tua and everybody seems to love him
that's around him
doesn't this help explain why he was
yanked from a couple definitely if he
really didn't have full access to the
playbook i mean we're getting down to
crunch time here we got a chance to win
this game right we can't screw around
with remedial offense exactly in the guy
who knows the offense inside now 100
mike uh
no question about it yeah like yeah the
remedial offense or like hey it's crunch
time and we need a guy that okay it's
third and seven and all of a sudden
they're bringing some crazy blitz he's
gonna get to that right check that tuba
said he wasn't comfortable with so now
wait we got the the four-week blitz the
will free safety's blocked up and now
everything's good and i could throw the
ball and make the right throw into that
coverage and blitz and all those type of
things exactly right so they were
handicapped or handcuffed that way and
that's a certainly a big part of the
reason i would think that yes he was out
of those games in those situations
and what he said yesterday would help
explain why he wasn't upset
with that i think he understood yes yeah
i'm probably not the best guy to be in
here in these moments with the game on
the line given the fact that i'm still
getting comfortable with this nfl
offense so yeah i i agree look i
we love to it just because we point out
that
maybe the dolphins will get to sean
watson if they can maybe they thought
about taking a quarterback this year all
these other issues i mean we saw it when
joe burrow and justin herbert were as
good as they were last year it becomes
glaring
that the guy who was tied to the tank
four phrase right in 2019
wasn't the best of the bunch yeah and
and and he was by far number three and
everyone knows it so he knows it too and
he knows what he needs to do to get
better and i agree with you chris he
he's gonna be in in good shape uh and
he's going to have friends and
supporters in the locker room and he
does let's hear from mike gaseki
dolphins tight end who spoke with
reporters yesterday and defended his
quarterback
yeah i think if you look at you know his
his past you know career you know
daytona back to college i think you know
he's been put in you know big positions
and you know made plays he's dealt with
you know adversity um whether it's you
know injury or whatever it may be um
fought back from that and uh you know
he's
he's also dealt with you know people
saying you know stupid uneducated stuff
about them that you know they're not
right about so um so he's dealing with
that and he's you know continuing to
work and continuing to you know come in
here each and every day and uh you know
i'm happy that you know he's our
quarterback the problem with the with
the criticism is it's
it's not you know there's nothing behind
it you know i mean the kid came in here
and you know people were already you
know calling for him i mean played nine
games and he played you know did a lot
of really good things for us um you know
stepped up in some big situations you
know made plays um
and i think got better each and every
week and now you know everybody's you
know been you know talking about us
about his confidence and you know how he
looks you know this year obviously in a
couple of you know walk-throughs and all
that kind of stuff but still you know
looks good
and um you know been working hard and
you know investing a lot of time into
this season and uh so i'm excited for
you know his his future
you know i think he's just going to
continue to
you know focus on what's important and
you know the opinions that are important
because at the end of the day you know
that's really all that matters uh is you
know the people inside this building and
you know um the guys upstairs and the
guys in the locker room and i can tell
you that you know firsthand the guys in
the locker room you know we all believe
in we all respect them and now we're all
excited about them
i think one of the reasons kasich says
that is because of the candor that we
saw earlier in the segment from tua
right because he acknowledges that there
were issues last year and he's doing
what he has to do to improve and become
the best quarterback he can be and it
wins over your teammates and it makes
them into your friends when you are
honest about your shortcomings and not
obsessed with trying to conceal them
that's right well now he feels
comfortable too that if something
happens on a play like the quarterback's
got his back whether gaseki messes up or
maybe he didn't mess up and tuba said
the wrong thing in the huddle and now
the coaches yell at gaseki because they
think you're wrong like you know he
probably feels like well two is the kind
of guy that's going to be like no no
coach that was me
that's you can get great respect that
way you know i know that happened to me
just luckily a few times in my career i
can remember sitting in a meeting one
day
and i said the wrong thing in a friday
practice and mike alstott ran the wrong
route and you know when nothing was
really said at the time you know gruden
made a face or whatever during practice
but then the next morning we're watching
that film and he kind of gets on mike
alstom like what the hell what are you
doing and i you know raised my hand i
was like oh no no that was my fault i
messed that up and
like the team erupted that i did that
they erupted they were like banging on
the table and like yeah like and that's
just a you know i'm just showing a
little light of what that can be in a
locker room that's really good there and
that's where i am excited for tua his
leadership skills and he did do some
good things last year there's no doubt
about it the problem with tua is
there were rumors of the lack of buzz of
being impressed right by by people down
there we knew that that was i think a
real thing and then the fact that the
dolphins actually played joe burrow and
justin herbert and they got to like
study them and see them and they went
wait our guys not doing that so that
added to maybe the pressure on the tua
situation as well
by the way i had to smile when you say
gruden made a face he has one face yeah
right he makes it's the face yeah he
carries her out all the time it's his
resting face
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports